il voulait changer nevers incarner le
renouvellement
après six ans de mandat denis thériault
se retrouve à son tour dans la position
du sortant chantier sur le patrimoine
virage numérique revitalisation du
centre ville
l'heure est au bilan assumer je pense
qu'on a fait bouger n'aurait on a
beaucoup travaillé et puis oui à côté je
pense qu'on nous remonte donc de
réalisation et il ya encore beaucoup à
faire mais en tout cas 95 % de nos
engagements ont été faits et il
s'agissait de remettre nos verres à
niveau en 2014 l'union avec la droite
lui avait permis de l'emporter à la tête
d'une liste sans étiquette
cette année même paris à une différence
près denis curio fait partie des
premiers candidats investis par la
république en marche et dans un contexte
de contestation sociale
il veut croire que ce ne sera pas un
handicap moi j'ai un soutien je ne m'en
cache pas mais c'est pas pour ça que ce
soutien c'est lui qui fait ma vie c'est
lui qui fait le projet donc voilà il n'y
a pas de difficultés mais tous ensemble
avant j'étais ex ps maintenant je suis
soutenue par la république en marche
mais je restais pas le problème on est
tous ensemble pour nos verres face à lui
la gauche rêve d'un retour pour effacer
le traumatisme de 2014 mais en ordre
dispersé premier à se lancer nevers
écologique et solidaire menée par le duo
nathalie chardy et françois diot
conseillers municipaux d'opposition
écologistes et communistes
nous sommes à gauche tous les
revendiquons et nous espérons bien que
ces valeurs là qui sont très loin quand
même des valeurs macro nice tu puisses
en effet retrouvé droit de cité dans la
belle ville de nevers pourtant les
négociations pour une liste commune ont
abouti à une impasse pour le premier
tour les deux préalables c'est que nous
ne voulions pas d'accord d'appareil et
nous voulions un renouvellement de
personnes il se trouve que cette
philosophie n'a pas été partagée et nous
nous étonnons nous regrettons empêcher
que l'union n'est pas pu se faire
car à nevers ancien bastion socialiste
la gauche plurielle n'est plus qu'un
souvenir
le ps et ses dérivés défendent leur
propre rassemblement à part derrière la
liste nevers en commun avec à sa tête
une militante france insoumise
emilie chami l'aspect citoyen ne
permettaient pas d'intégrer toutes les
composantes de tous les partis de la
gauche et une souhaitions incarner ce
grand rassemblement de plusieurs partis
politiques de gauche mais aussi citoyen
de gilet jaune
l'enjeu c'est donc d'exister
indépendamment au premier tour au risque
d'éparpiller les votes tout en pensant
déjà au second et à une potentielle
fusion des listes
le pari n'est pas risqué nous
représentons nous incarnons un grand
rassemblement déjà sur notre liste
absolument pas exprès pense rejoignent
plus tard une multiplication des
candidatures dont espère profiter le
rassemblement national en embuscade
nevers n'a jamais vraiment souri à
l'extrême droite mais damien beaudry
vaut cette année une opportunité
l'électorat populaire se détournent de
plus en plus de la gauche pour se
rapprocher nous est aujourd'hui la seule
liste de droite qui est représenté sur
nevers c'est la nôtre donc nous avons
double chance d'accéder au pouvoir de la
municipalité
et si la victoire n'est pas au
rendez-vous le rn entend bien s'appuyer
sur ce scrutin pour s'implanter
localement nous allons pouvoir créer au
minimum un groupe ce qu'on n'a jamais
eue sur la ville et donc à voir
un pouvoir politique un pouvoir
d'opposition confirmation revanche ou
surprise à nevers l'historique récent
incite à se méfier des pronostics
d'autant qu'en cas de second tour
la donne pourrait encore changer